we're gonna unpack the reasons for this
ratings bonanza in our seen and unseen
segment coming up with Raymond Arroyo
but meanwhile the conservative enclave
of Orange County California has just
become the epicenter of the fight over
the Golden State sanctuary policies
yesterday an amazing move the Orange
County Board of Supervisors voted to
condemn California sanctuary law and
it's now joining a US Justice Department
lawsuit that claims the entire system
out there is unconstitutional joining us
now with reaction is Orange County
Supervisor Michelle Steele a legal
immigrant who get this was called a
racist B word over her willingness to
cooperate with ice along with Joe Alioto
very nice he's a former California
criminal justice Commissioner great to
see both of you let's start with you
Michelle when I read what they said
about you with your background I'd like
to say I was surprised but I wasn't
because if you buck the liberal trend in
California on an issue like immigration
they feel like they have free license to
call you any name in the book tell us
how your life has been in the 24 hours
since this decision was made
oh my god I'm very happy about it
because I was the one actually
introduced the resolution because our
local police our law enforcement
agencies their hands being tied so we
really have to work because as a
supervisor Orange County has to be you
know safe so public safety comes first
but it was really interesting because
you can hear that I speak Korean and
Japanese is my second language and you
know English is my third and I went
through those legal process and I know
legal immigrants and I was called racist
Big B it was just anyway I was surprised
but you know in Asia when you get call
all these names you have a long life so
I'm gonna have a long life oh my
goodness Joe I want to go to you I'm
sure you don't support the you know
calling there were snipers I knew you I
know you
I'm not dragging you into that but it is
thank you
it's hard it's that's horrific I know
you condemn that but let's talk about
what's happened since the you know the
big faceoff for the Trump administration
California is seeing one large County
three million people revolt against this
do you blame Orange County for voting
the way they did given the fact that
they don't want Orange County to turn
into San Francisco meaning they don't
want the hypodermic needles in the
streets they don't want the human feces
all over all these blocks they don't
want the homelessness problem and they
don't want crime they don't want what
San Francisco has double the rate of the
the state crime crime rate in San
Francisco's defense we don't want any of
that stuff either but as far as what
Orange County is doing this I think is
just another political stunt it's a lot
like what the federal government is
doing on the lawsuit I questioned
whether or not the supervisors
resolution will get passed the attorneys
on this the lawsuit that was filed by
ice was filed against the state of
California on preemption issues that the
federal law preempts state law I think
that law has actually been settled
nobody here is arguing that that state
law preempts federal law I think what
the feds are saying is that we are
interfering by telling our citizens and
by telling our state representatives not
to enforce immigration law and and I
think I think the only way that the feds
are going to actually win on that
argument is if there's some sort of
federal funding that's attached to it
otherwise I don't see them the window as
far as the county is concerned
preemption is not they don't have
jurisdiction here because preemption is
not their argument well we'll lose the
entire viewing audience here but let's
get let's get right to the nut of what's
going on here we have a resolution in
Orange County that now requires that you
announce and Michelle correct me if I'm
wrong you announced when it when a
prisoner is released correct you will
announce it so people know when they
were they will be released why would
anyone be against that the last three
months we had 172
criminal aliens were released on the
street as a supervisor I already told
you it's like a public safety comes
first so immigration is under the
federal law and then this is totally
unconstitutional law in the state that
they just created
they created the chaos for between local
government and federal government
working together so this one has to be
stopped that's the reason that Jeff
Sessions sued and then now we are
joining Jeff session we just boil this
all down guys this is about safety this
is about security this is about the the
well-being of citizens citizens of the
United States and legal immigrants and
Joe I want to play for you this is a
Xavier Becerra the Attorney General
yesterday the day before yesterday
talking about this situation let's watch
state law state law and it's my job to
enforce state law I will I will do so
and we want to make sure that every
jurisdiction including Orange County
understand what state law requires of
the people and the subdivisions of the
state of California
I think I just answered so I'm picturing
this because we've had these types of
crimes horrific crimes and illegal alien
rapes a ten-year-old girl and does his
time and then is released there are
sanctuary politicians who believe the
federal government should not be
notified and that individual should be
put back out on the streets in a
sanctuary State Joe is that what you're
in favor to talk no no if you're talking
about somebody that has been convicted
tried and convicted I am NOT one of
those political people that would
believe that that person should be back
on the streets that's happening all the
time to me as a violent criminal what
we're talking about though is due
process because a lot of these people
that the supervisors talking about that
are being released from jail some of
them are being released on bail released
on oh are but these are people that have
merely been arrested these are not
people that have been prosecuted and
tried and people in the United States
unfortunately for ice the Fourteenth
Amendment applies and and and it
requires that people get due process
before they're actually convicted before
you can say that this person they're in
the country illegally they're
immediately supportable aliens they're
in the country elisa shoot that's ice
enforcement ice can come pick them up
and get them out of the country I mean
we act like these we police who are
talking about our American citizens they
are not citizens this is not their
country they came in illegally and now
they want the red carpet rolled out
which I guess California does Michelle
you go ahead yeah we can go back to San
Francisco what happened because
Francisco Sanchez that who was convicted
for seven times and who was deported for
five times city of San Francisco refused
to give a transfer him two eyes and
guess what happened Caylee Stanley got
killed so this is exactly what we want
to prevent that's why we want to get out
of that sanctuary State and sanctuary
you know against the sanctuary states
the Orange County can be safe we always
want to come safe first
so our our Sheriff
chants who decide to put all the list up
will a mate release that the list is
coming out on in public so everybody can
see it you know what she isn't really
right thing and pretend yesterday that
Becerra is gonna arrest him
I mean arrested her it's almost
ridiculous now so the sheriff's are
gonna get arrested and the illegals will
get released that's great so the
sheriff's actually try to keep people
today they're gonna be arrested by the
state any illegal immigrants get to go
free Joe final point goes to sheriffs
will have to follow state law and if the
if the County of Orange County wants a
challenge state law they should file a
separate lawsuit I don't think that this
is the right place I think this is a
political stunt and as far as the Kate
Steinle case horrible horrible
circumstances but the facts on exactly
what happened and how many Americans
have to be sacrificed for this this
fantasy that open borders is a good
thing I mean I just keep asking is how
many Americans have to die in DUIs be
brutalized women be abused and domestic
abuse children be you know horrible
things done to them how often does this
have to happen until people say but no
more cannot do it any citizens no
medicines are doing that ice needs to
enforce federal immigration policy the
state doesn't know California wants to
put out the welcome mat because San
Francisco doesn't have enough troubles
where the homelessness crisis with a
with it with the filth and the streets
that report that came out a couple of
weeks ago if I'm San Francisco I want to
try to clean up you know our act here
but you guys want to bring more people
in who cause more problems I don't
understand that but for the life of me I
will never understand that but we're out
of time guys Joe great segment Michelle
we appreciate it
thank you very much